- All right, welcome everyone.
Give me a thumbs up if the audio is good.
Let's see.
Wanna make sure everyone can hear me.
Awesome.
My name is Roland Barcia.
I'm the worldwide director
for our specialist technology team,
and I have the honor and
privilege to be here with Mridula.
You wanna introduce yourself?
- For sure.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Mridula Grandhi,
and I lead the go-to-market
for North America
for specialist SAs.
I'm happy to be here and be talking
about unlocking agentic
AI for microservices.
- Thank you.
Thank you for joining us, by the way,
in the evening 05:30, not a great slot.
I know people want to go have nice dinners
and things at this time,
so really appreciate you all being here.
Thank you so much.
So, let's get started.
I'm gonna go through the animations quick,
'cause I really wanna have a
conversation with the audience.
I wish it was a little
bit more two-way here,
but obviously, AI applications
have really exploded.
I mean, how many sessions
were there this week
with the word agents in it?
Agents is everywhere.
We're entering the agentic age,
and it's really important to understand
what that means for your existing systems,
your existing microservices,
your existing applications.
I wanna get started a little
bit with agent-driven design
and agent applications.
We've spent many years
building microservices.
Mridula is gonna talk
about that in a minute,
but agentic applications
have really emerged
as a new pattern,
and there's a lot of
differences between them.
So for example, very
stateful applications,
very data-intensive, very conversational,
there's a lot of different principles.
The DevOps is different in many ways.
You're doing things like evaluations.
We announced agent core
evaluation today, for example.
We're doing things with MLOps,
we're doing a lot of
different things with data.
We wanna make sure we can get at the data,
get insights from the data,
and we wanna make sure we have guardrails.
We wanna make sure it's
enhancing human ability
to do things faster and more
effectively with more quality.
And these are all aspects
of agent-driven design.
Now, a lot of the early
agentic applications,
were static workflows.
Oftentimes, stitching together agents
through workflow tools,
BPM tools, et cetera.
We worked with a telco provider.
One of the teams I run
is the prototyping team.
And we spend a lot of
times helping customers,
build their first agent,
their first agent use cases.
This one is a very interesting one for me,
and it kind of highlights
some of the themes
we're gonna talk about.
We worked on this SRE agent,
and what we wanted to do
is have a metric, a goal.
They wanted to get from 30,
40 minutes problem resolution,
down to five minutes.
And so, you know, we can solve
this with agentic behavior,
but a lot of the things
and systems they needed were
locked inside of applications.
And so, they wanted information
about their Kubernetes EKS cluster,
they wanted information
about their metrics server,
they wanted observability information,
and they had built a wealth
of knowledge around runbooks.
So, we built these existing
systems and exposed them
through the model context protocol.
Mridula's gonna talk a
little bit about that later.
That's MCP, if you're living under a rock,
is like everywhere, right?
There's like probably more MCP servers,
and there are people using
MCP servers in many ways.
But we built an SRE agent
that really modeled workflows,
after their existing
patterns and runbooks,
and they were able to really
resolve a bunch of the issues
that they had in production
a lot more quickly.
And these are examples of the power
of taking your existing
deterministic code,
deterministic operations and exposing them
through a common API,
and then being able to build
orchestration and workflows,
and they were able to not only get
to what is the issue quicker,
but actually, take
resolution steps with agents
and take actions on them as well.
This is the power of
agentic behavior being able
to stitch these things
and automate the things
that we wanna automate
so we can focus on value.
But microservices is a challenge,
and with that, Mridula is
gonna talk a little bit
about some of this.
- All right, let me start with
the question for the room.
How many of you are actually
running microservices
on production today?
And a quick show of hands.
- [Roland] Should be everyone.
- That's awesome.
And keep your hands up,
if you have agents already
accessing them on production.
Okay, that's what I thought.
We've been running microservices
on production successfully,
but now AI agents want in club.
Think of it like this.
We've either started
directly with microservices
or decomposed monolith
applications into microservices.
We now have a fleet of microservices each
with its own API
databases, business logic.
All the services are
talking fluently in rest,
but agents only understand
why coding, just kidding.
When we are bringing agents
into the enterprise world,
agents that can plan
reason, break down tasks,
execute the tools, and
actually achieve the outcome
that you want them to achieve.
And when you expose them
into the microservices world,
they'll be like, "Okay, cool endpoints.
What do you want us to do with it?"
This is where the context
engineering comes into picture.
In the microservices environment,
context engineering is
where you tell the agents
what services exist,
which ones it's actually
allowed to call, in what order,
under which preconditions,
and how do you recover from failure?
And if it's actually done right,
you're turning a flat list of APIs
into a map of capabilities,
constraints, and workflows,
exactly the environment
that agents can thrive.
So the real problem is
actually not the logic.
The logic is already existing
in your microservices applications.
The real problem is the exposure.
How do you surface the
already existing logic
that's there in your microservices
into a structured contextual
and a truly agent-friendly way
so that your agents can start
talking to your microservices
and build the new agentic systems?
Now, think about it from
your environment perspective.
What does it take for you
to actually expose your
microservices to the agents
so that you're truly unlocking that value,
and actually unlocking
to the next level of enterprise
scale agentic automation?
Now, before we dive deep into AI agents,
let's make sure that we are actually,
all speaking the same
language of microservices.
Foundationally, a microservice
is a simple deployable unit
that has a specific business function,
and can talk to each other
and also external data sources
through rest endpoints or
well-defined endpoints, right?
Think of it like Lego blocks.
Each block has a specific
function that does it well,
but when you snap them together,
you're actually creating
something amazing.
Now, there are six
principles of microservices
that I want you all to underscore.
First is service independence.
Each service is a standalone application
or with its own database
and deployment lifecycle.
Think of it like roommates
with separate bank accounts.
Second is single responsibility.
One service, one job, done well.
Third is decentralized communication.
Services talk in well-defined endpoints
or APIs not directly access the database.
Fourth is agnostic tech stack.
Service A can be written in
Python, service B in Java,
service C in Rust, do whatever fits well.
Fifth is system resiliency.
One failure doesn't crash
your entire application,
just like a flat tire doesn't
bring the entire highway down.
And the last is the
independent deployability.
You can deploy, update,
and roll back your services
without impacting other services.
These six principles are what
make microservices powerful.
And once you master these,
you're actually ready to
understand the AI agents
and how it unlocks to the next level.
Now, let's look at how some of the aspects
that we discuss on this
slide could be helpful
for you to think about
rethinking microservices
in the agentic era.
Now on the left, you have the
core microservice constructs.
You've got your data layer,
where you store your databases,
you've got your events flowing
through the message queues,
you've got your business logic,
the code that makes the decision,
the brain of your business.
And if you've got your communication,
the rest APIs talking to each
other, pretty straightforward.
Now on the right,
what you have are the
AI AgentCore constructs.
And when you infuse these
into your microservices,
you're adding four new capabilities.
The first is the reasoning.
Reasoning is the agent's
ability to solve problems.
Chain of thought,
is the agent explaining
its reasoning out loud.
Chain of thought transforms
what you see as a black box
to actually a glass box,
because you get to see every
decision that is being made.
And especially, that's important,
when you are orchestrating your services
in a production environment.
Next is the memory.
You have two different types
of memory fundamentally.
And today, we've launched
episodic memory as well,
and we'll talk about it later.
But the short-term and long-term memory,
especially the conversational
and the operational context,
is stored for agents.
And your microservices architecture,
becomes an extensible toolkit
that agents can include via tools.
And the last aspect is the learning.
The agents improvise through
feedback loops every iteration
of their execution.
Now, here's the key difference.
The old way you have to
hard code everything,
call service A, then
service B, then service C.
It's rigid, it's deterministic,
it works until it doesn't.
The new way is how you
actually give an agent a goal,
something like reduce
incident response time,
and it figures out which
services to call, in what order,
and actually, what's happening,
and train accordingly in
terms of what's happening
in your environment.
Let's talk about when you
should actually use AI agents.
It's not about jumping
onto the hype train,
it's about focusing on
three key principles.
The first is start with real problem.
Use cases like clinical
workflow automation
for healthcare where agents,
can proactively analyze your
patient medical history,
identify trends and flag potential issues
or market analyst agents
and financial services
where it identifies the
market opportunities
to reduce research time,
so that the investment analysts,
can focus on higher value strategic work,
are some of the examples
of real use cases.
Determine your key metrics,
things like turnaround time reduction,
staff productivity improvements,
and time to insight are some
good examples of key metrics
that you may want to define
as KPIs for your agents.
And lastly, assess the potential impact.
Consider both business value and risk.
For business impact, things like ROI,
which is return of investment,
operational efficiency,
customer satisfaction,
are some of the examples.
And for risk assessment,
think about what happens
when your agent fails.
Do you have human in the loop?
If not, what would it take to make sure
that your services are seamless?
So start with high impact problems,
define metrics upfront,
assess both upside and failure modes,
and get these three things right
and the technology becomes the easy part.
Now I let Roland continue
with what it takes
in terms of tools and
positioning the tools and agents.
- Thank you, Mridula.
So as we continue here,
one of the things I just wanna follow up.
To be honest, when we're talking
about AI use cases and agents,
oftentimes people or some of
the agents that we're building,
it's a technology looking for a problem
in some cases, right?
The reality is business use
cases drive what you need to do.
And it could be some
of it is deterministic,
some of it is non-deterministic,
the business problems live on their own.
And then AI can kind of help automate,
do certain things better, do
certain automations better.
There's probably lots of
things you can look at
at existing systems and take a look at
that would be easy to automate with AI.
If you ever build business
process workflow applications,
you've probably seen big
branches of conditional code
that goes into different leafs.
Those are good opportunities
for agentic modernization.
Let's talk a little bit
about building agents.
More or less in a nutshell,
agents of piece of code,
you might write it in Python, Strands.
We just announced
Strands' TypeScript today,
some really exciting.
We write some agents in TypeScript.
There's other frameworks,
and you're really doing a combination
of goals and instructions.
So you have your system prompts,
you have your tools,
your deterministic logic,
we gave examples of that earlier.
And then you have things in your context.
Context engineering is really
becoming very strategic
in guiding the agent in where
and what decisions to make,
what tools to use, what data to go act
or what actions to go after.
As you build more and more agents,
you get a lot, a lot of tools,
and you need that context
to really help your agent
make the right decisions.
You wanna be able to guide the agents,
you're right to make those decisions.
And then you have observability.
You wanna be able to measure
the results of the agents,
make sure you're getting
the answers you want.
Go beyond what you get in chatbot today,
is like thumbs up, thumbs down.
Did you like the answer?
How do you do observability
and successful metrics
in an observable way?
These are some of the
challenges around that, right?
Agents need tools and they need content.
And there's different
ways to do this, right?
There's web scraping,
navigation interactions,
LLMs are good.
There's techniques like LLMS text files
that you can put into websites,
for example, to help models.
You have workflows and automations
that you need to do tasks.
Usually, these are located
inside of MCP servers,
that's what we wanna get out
of our existing applications.
Then you have knowledge bases as well,
and you have your existing data,
and that data is structured
and unstructured.
So this is definitely the things
that the agents work with.
Some of those things,
again, are available there.
I'm gonna give it back to Mridula
to talk a little bit about MCP, yeah.
- Thank you.
All right, remember the early 2000s,
every device had a
different power adapter?
It used to be a nightmare
to manage all of those.
Then USBC happened.
And that's exactly what's
happening right now
in the AI agentic space,
especially when we have
so many agents talking
to different tools and content.
We need an adapter to make sure
that all of this is
flowing through seamlessly.
Model context protocol is an
open source protocol developed
by anthropic and emerging
to be a standard operating protocol along
with the agent to agent.
But specifically, when it comes
to agents talking to tools,
MCP plays a critical role given the fact
that MCP is better with respect
to agentic tools communication.
So we will dive deep on
this protocol followed
by Roland taking over on A2A.
So MCP follows a client
host server architecture
for your agents.
Firstly, the host has your
AI agents, LLMs, and IDs,
that will be requesting
access to the data sources.
Then you have the MCP client,
which maintains the one-to-one connection
with your MCP server.
And an important thing to note here is,
MCP client can establish
multiple transport layers,
which means that you
can actually get a mix
of deployment modes without
to rewrite agentic code.
The MCP server is a lightweight program
that exposes this capabilities
of your microservices
through the standardized MCP protocol.
And lastly, we have the data sources,
both local resources
like databases and files,
and remote services via
APIs can be accessed
through the MCP server.
So the key point to note here is MCP,
is action-oriented and deterministic.
All it takes care of is
the protocol translation,
but not the decision-making.
That's where your agents
come into the picture.
Now, before MCP,
building GenAI applications
was like a plumber in a house
where every room has a
different pipe standard.
Your application needs to call
GitHub, custom integration,
Slack, another custom integration,
your own databases, yet another one.
Each with different
authentication methods,
data formats, and communication protocols.
So if you have about
five applications talking
to 10 different tools, you
have 50 different integrations.
And here's the kicker.
When Slack updates its
API tomorrow morning,
you'll end up rewriting
that code across every single application
that invokes the Slack.
It's a nightmare to handle
the integration complexity
and not exactly the future
that we've signed up for.
With MCP, you get one unified API layer,
your application needs or speaks
to one protocol that is MCP
and the protocol handles the translation
to each service's unique API.
One integration point
for your application,
but actually, standardized access
to an expanding list of tools.
And that's the fundamental
shift we are talking about,
from custom integrations
to standardized simplicity,
from spending weeks debugging
the authentication methods
and API versioning to shipping AI features
in hours if not days.
Now, Roland is gonna cover the A2A.
- Yeah, and so we wanted
to cover this a little bit.
We're not gonna go too deep,
but as we're thinking about microservices,
one of the big things about microservices,
was always reuse, right?
How do I reuse my existing applications?
Agents need to do the same thing.
I need to build agents, and
they're used by other agents.
That's how you build orchestration,
non-deterministic workflows,
calling other non-deterministic workflows,
and A2A really addresses that problem.
One, there's tons of agents out there,
so how do I discover them?
The A2A protocol has
a discovery mechanism.
Task management, you have different agents
that do different tasks.
Collaboration, how do you
share things like context?
How do you share things
like security, et cetera?
And these are important things
to talk about when you're building agents.
You wanna think about your
agents the same way you think
about microservices and
expose them to other agents
and other orchestration, and other tools,
and even frontends.
Actually had a code talk earlier today,
it's should be up on YouTube already.
That kind of shows an
example of us taking an agent
and exposing it through MCP
and deploying it to AgentCore Runtime.
So let's talk a little bit
about now the process of going through
and taking your existing applications,
your existing microservices,
exposing them through tools, right?
You wanna define, describe your APIs.
How many people used things like Swagger
in the past to define RESTful APIs?
Well, Mridula talked about
microservices principles earlier.
The reality is,
we probably haven't written
perfect microservices
that have one data
source per microservice,
and do all those things, right?
We probably have a
combination of monoliths
through microservices, and
maybe you don't have those APIs.
You can use something
like Kiro to generate some
of those OpenAPI's
Swagger documents, right?
You want structured interfaces.
So JSON, OpenAPI, gRPC or other metrics,
you need security and guardrails.
How do you access them?
And then you need feedback loops,
observability, retries, et cetera.
Now, when we're getting into
exposing your microservices,
there's choices, you can code
and write your own MCP servers
in code, make it part of your application,
maintain it with your code.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Oftentimes, why would you do that?
You wanna take full
advantage of the MCP protocol
in addition to tools.
It has things like resources
and prompt templates.
So you wanna be able to
standardize on those.
You might code some special
purpose MCP servers,
but when you have hundreds or
thousands of microservices,
you may want an easy button.
And that's why having something
like AgentCore Gateway,
which we'll talk about,
to kind of expose your
existing tools as MCP servers,
might be a huge accelerator
for your existing systems.
So you can kind of think about
which MCP servers you wanna code,
which ones you wanna expose,
which ones you wanna combine, et cetera,
and have those capabilities.
A lot of the early MCP servers
that were built out were read only, right?
So we'd have an ordering
agent, pricing agent,
you go to MCP Gateway,
you go get your promotions
or list your promotions, et cetera,
and then kind of goes into
your existing systems,
access your presentation
layer or your REST APIs,
your BFF services, best friends forever
or backend for frontends,
that's what that means.
And then kind of expose it.
And that was easy.
Some of the security
behind that's a bit easier.
But now, things are evolving, right?
So you know, you're gonna
have lots of existing APIs,
you're gonna have lots of
existing MCP tools, right?
Then you're gonna have MCP servers,
and then you could expose them
through a gateway to
make things a lot easier
for you, right?
There's different patterns
with MCP gateways, for example,
you might wanna get REST APIs,
you might have existing Lambda functions,
you might have existing
MCP servers, et cetera.
And we didn't catch the typo.
My name was in the header there, oops.
And so some design principles, right?
When you're building
model-driven approach to agent,
you wanna think about your consumers.
We have developers.
Some agents are gonna be
naturally consumed by developers.
consumed by business users.
I know we have a lot of
low code, no code tools,
like Quick Suite, which is an
awesome way for your BI people
to build agents and automation,
against your different data sources.
But you wanna be able to get and build
for developers, simple code solutions.
You want reasoning capabilities,
and you want model and deployment choices.
So the reality is building agents is hard.
I say building them, building examples,
building POCs are fairly easy.
Getting them to production is hard,
learning all the best practices is hard.
You have to start thinking
about things like,
"I have hundreds and
hundreds of MCP tools,
and then I send a request,
I said, 'Give me a list
of tools, da da da da.'
I get the answer back,
and then I tell the chat
agent, 'Thank you.'"
What's it gonna do?
It's gonna send thank you
back with the list of tools
and the context.
You don't wanna pay for the tokens
for the list of tools and build that up.
Lots of different new best practices
that are emerging around those things.
And so we control
guardrails, all these things,
limited visibility,
observability is a challenge.
Things are generated,
you get responses, they're dynamic.
It's really hard to observe
dynamic code, right?
So it's challenging, it's
hard to maintain, why?
Because models keep coming out,
new versions of models come out,
and you start building up
a prompt library of things
to test answers.
And then you know, brand
new model comes out,
you run your tests and all
the answers are off, right?
So DevOps and MLOps crashing
together, different things.
And so Strands really
helps with a lot of this.
Mridula, you wanna talk a
little bit about Strands?
- All right, let's talk
about Strands Agents.
Strands Agents is an open source SDK,
that lets you build AI agents
in just a few lines of code.
Amazon has actually built this
and published this as an open source.
No complex workflows, no
orchestration nightmares,
just you, a prompt, and a list of tools.
Why should you use Strands?
Let's start with ease of use.
Remember the last time you
tried to build an agent,
and spend three days,
figuring out the orchestration framework?
With Strands, it's just
four lines of code.
You've got a working agent, no YAML files,
no complex configuration,
no sacrificing your
weekend to stack overflow.
Internally, our Amazon Q developer team,
used Strands to publish our agentic chat
in just three weeks,
and GitLab Duo integration
in just six weeks.
What previously took months,
now just takes weeks.
And that's the difference between
we'll have them ship next quarter,
versus we've already
shipped them last Tuesday.
When it comes to robust capabilities,
Strands comes with about
more than 20 prebuilt tools,
whether it's file requests, web services,
operations, and custom integration
with AWS service tools directly.
So if you want to integrate directly
with Glue or Amazon VPC
Reachability Analyzer,
or even a Snowflake database,
MCP got you covered there,
and Strands got you
covered there through MCP.
Because Strands comes
with a native MCP support,
and we've also recently launched
eight-way support for Strands.
Extensibility is where
Strands really shine,
because you are not locked in
on one single-model provider.
You can use Amazon's
Bedrock, Anthropic's Claude,
or any other Mistral AI or
Stability AI model provider,
the choice is yours.
And we have support over
100 LLM providers there.
So rapid development means
you get to go from idea
to working prototype in minutes, not days.
You can test easily on local machines.
It read fast and deploy to
production whenever you're ready.
So given the agents
are autonomous systems,
even building a basic agent,
requires piecing together
numerous complex components,
such as orchestration, tool execution,
and state management.
Open source frameworks
like LangGraph, CrewAI,
and Strand Agents are making it easy
for developers to get
started and build prototypes.
While these frameworks,
have simplified building
a working agent prototype,
developers still hit a
brick wall when you attempt
to actually build an application
that can scale to millions
of end users in production.
So I let Roland unpack the key components
and the challenges that we are facing
and how AWS can actually help.
- Thank you, Mridula.
So let's get a little bit,
we've already talked about AgentCore,
which we announced earlier in the year,
obviously, missing from
here is the new policy
and the gateway and the
valuation frameworks.
But AgentCore, we built
it in a very specific way.
When we think about platforms,
we know a lot of our
customers build platforms,
and they have different choices.
So we build AgentCore in a way
that you can use the different
pieces interchangeably
in different ways.
So you don't have to use all of it,
but if you use all of it,
you get a lot of advantages.
AgentCore Runtime, which you get into,
provides a serverless runtime environment
for you to build agents.
We have Memory, so we talked
about things like short-term,
long-term summary,
episodic, which was just announced today.
All these different
patterns that were emerging.
Identity, which allows us to securely,
have our agents access
securely and also access tools
and third-party agents securely as well.
AgentCore Gateway, which
we're gonna get into deeper,
really, is the ability to expose
your existing MCP servers,
your existing APIs, lambda
functions and integrations
to your agents.
Code Interpreter, it'll let you,
as a lot of agents generate code,
run it on the fly.
You wanna do that in a
safe sandbox environment,
and a set of browser
tools and Observability
to help you see how your agents
are performing and doing.
And so with Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore, right,
you can build with the Runtime,
you can have tools discovered
easily semantically
through the gateway with semantic search.
Saves a lot of money in token costs,
short-term and long-term
memory, episodic as well.
And summaries end-to-end
tracing and visibility,
and full-managed browser tools
and code interpreter capabilities.
Get a little bit deeper when we're talking
about applications, right?
You wanna have an application,
wanna have an agent,
you wanna use your favorite framework
as Mridula talked about, such as Strands,
TypeScript announced
today release, woo-hoo.
For those people that don't
always wanna do Python,
deploy that into your
serverless environment.
Talk to any model that you want,
can be hosted on Bedrock
with all the model choices.
Could be hosted in silicon
like Trainium, et cetera,
Trainium3, NVIDIA instances, et cetera.
Then you have AgentCore
Memory for the patterns,
ready for production, AgentCore
Observability, Identity,
all your tools and your
existing applications,
and your interpreter and browser.
This is really exciting
because we find getting to
production is a challenge.
We think we build a really
good end-to-end environment
in a modular way to help
you get to production.
We have lots of customers
already in production with agents
with tons of different customers.
So Gateway, we have a nice
little animation there.
We're going to, I think,
Mridula surprised me with the animation.
So you know, we have the gateway,
which we're gonna kind of
concentrate into, right?
AgentCore Runtime, really
exciting, serverless.
So, but you can take your
existing application,
all you have to do is
put it in a container.
You could also do it just the code itself.
There's a zip, a faster
way to do it as well.
But a lot of customers
like to deploy containers.
They have a DevOps pipeline
that knows how to publish to ECR.
So you can keep your existing DevOps,
deploy your agent as a container,
and then it's automatically
deployed and running.
There's a lot of coding talks this week.
Please go see them online if you haven't,
especially the one I
just did earlier today.
Use case independent, very
much like microservices,
secure, isolated and isolated environment
so that your agent can run
without having security
boundaries crossed.
And so it's very simple, right?
You take your agent,
your tools and your code,
you write your code, your decorators,
your different applications,
you configure a docker file,
push it into ECR, automatically
your runtime agent is there.
Your endpoints, which could be A2A,
could be other types of endpoints as well,
and your application can
invoke it, nice and simple.
AgentCore Gateway.
Now, AgentCore Gateway is fairly exciting.
We had a session earlier
today, like I said,
where you can take your applications,
your tools, and expose your APIs,
OpenAPI and Smithy are examples of that,
but just I just opened the account,
and I saw API Gateway is in there as well.
So your AgentCore Gateway can access APIs,
and API Gateway integrations,
or third-party MCP servers
that already exist.
This gives you a unified point
in your organization to say,
hey, these are supported, secured,
verified MCP tools.
With the new policy engine,
you can have security policies there.
You could say these tools
can only be executed
by these agents, and these
different types of patterns
that you want with a certain contact.
And then you have semantic search.
Semantic search is really important
because you can write an application
to do a semantic search
across thousands of tools
that won't send all of that to the LLM.
Instead, it'll give you
back the tools you want,
and save money,
especially you could send
the list of tools to the LLM,
let the LLM kind of determined.
But again, you're using a lot of tokens,
and if your application knows
what tools it needs to use,
that's a great pattern for you
to optimize and save money.
That's why we have intelligent discovery,
right, very simple.
You create a gateway instance,
you attach it to an identity provider
with AgentCore Identity, right?
You give it a target.
In this case,
we're talking about existing
RESTful service endpoints.
So here's an example of that.
And then you go and use semantic search
or use the application, say, list,
and invoke the tools, and you just use it,
fairly simple configuration.
That's kind of the key with that.
You also can do the same
pattern with Lambda.
We have lots, how many people have lots
of Lambda functions
deployed in production.
Lots, right, so you have your Lambda code,
your Lambda targets.
Lambda could be a good
quick way to stitch things
and support patterns that
we might not support yet.
For example, you might have private APIs
that are not accessible
through a VPC, et cetera.
You can use Lambda to
kind of bridge those gaps
and things like that as well.
Lambda's a great stitching tool for that.
It supports things like OAuth
with AgentCore Identity.
We actually showed the code for this
in the API gateway with
containers application
where we actually use the Python decorator
as we create the gateway
to refresh the token.
AgentCore Identity kind of
gives you these patterns
to do that very simply and very easily.
And of course, using AWS IAM to do that,
Identity gives you that
security capability for it.
Very similar, RESTful APIs
as well as other patterns like
Smithy and semantic search.
This is really, really huge to save money
if your agents know which
tools they wanna do,
get your list of MCP tools,
ask you questions, do semantic search,
and be able to get the different tools
that you might wanna
use in your application.
Search, you get back the
four most relevant tools
that you wanna use for your application.
You know, you might ask an
LLM to do this initially,
but you really wanna save money
and be important there as well.
Gonna hand it over.
We're doing a switch on purpose.
We thought it would be
funner to do it this way
because we're being agentic.
- All right, here's the challenge
with agents and microservices.
Traditional microservices
are stateless by design.
They don't remember anything
between the interactions,
but AI agents need
context to be effective.
Without memory, your agent
starts from scratch every time,
leading to repetitive questions,
slower responses, and higher costs,
as you pass the context
and the same context over
and over to your LLM.
AgentCore Memory solves this
by automatically storing
and indexing your agent's interactions
in a serverless architecture.
As a result, it reduces
the amount of context
that you need to pass to the LLM,
which means faster responses,
better accuracy, lower costs,
all while maintaining
enterprise-grade security
with encrypted data isolation.
So AgentCore Memory works very similar
to how human brain remembers information
through context and associations.
Short-term memory handles
your immediate context,
like chat messages and session state,
keeping track of what's
happening right now
in the conversation.
Long-term memory is where the
real intelligence emerges.
It stores the semantic information,
user preferences and summaries
that persisted across sessions,
and episodic memory captures
specific preferences
and experiences and
events with their temporal
and contextual interactions,
like remembering particular conversations,
what decisions were made or problem solved
in that past interaction.
The magic is in the
automatic memory extraction.
The system asynchronously processes
and organizes this memory
so you and your agent can
actually retrieve relevant context
from past interactions without you having
to manage any infrastructure.
That's the key aspect.
This means your agent learns
and improves over time.
Remembering user preferences
improvise past solutions
and the specific journey of interactions
that lead to the successful outcomes.
Here's a fundamental
challenge when it comes
to AI agents and microservices
that are set up in a distributed system.
And when it's calling enterprise services,
whether it's GitHub, Salesforce,
or even AWS Resources,
you're dealing with a complex
web of authentication methods.
Traditional approaches force you
to build custom authentication flows
for each service and migrate users,
or even create token management systems
that are often brittle.
AgentCore Identity solves this
by providing secure delegated access,
across your entire enterprise.
And this is done by providing
secure delegated access,
across different services,
whether it's Okta
or Microsoft Entra ID,
or even Amazon Cognito.
You don't have to migrate users.
All you have to do is make sure
that you have your credentials,
whether it's through the
keys or the IAM roles,
and you can accelerate your
agent development without having
to rebuild your authentication
infrastructure through this.
Now, the authentication
works in two directions,
both inbound and outbound.
Inbound authentication handles
how users and applications
in your microservices
actually invoke your agents,
whether it's through IAM or AWS resources.
And this is where
AgentCore Gateway validates
who's calling your agent
even if they're allowed
to do so or not.
Outbound authentication is
where your agent authentication
to external resources
and services are done
on behalf of the user.
And when your agent needs
to call the GitHub API
or query Salesforce,
or even access your AWS Lambda functions,
it uses the appropriate credentials,
whether it's OAuth tokens
or API keys or IAM roles
that we discussed, all managed
through a secure token vault.
And the beauty is
that AgentCore Gateway handles
both inbound and outbound
with a prebuilt-in
authentication and observability,
so you get the enterprise grade security
without any custom code.
Now, agents are
non-deterministic by nature.
They make autonomous decisions,
call multiple tools, and
execute complex workflows.
Without visibility, you are
actually flying blind here.
And when something goes
wrong, you can't debug it.
When performance degrades,
you cannot diagnose it.
And when you need to
maintain quality and trust
with your end user, you have
no evidence to show them.
This is where AgentCore
Observability solves this
by providing comprehensive
observability and visibility
into agent execution
and operational metrics,
across all AgentCore services.
You get real-time dashboards
that centralize agent health
and performance for
faster issue resolution.
And you can accelerate
your debugging capabilities
to quickly detect issues and
assess performance trends.
Custom attributes and
metadata are something
that you can actually customize.
And we've recently launched
AgentCore Evaluations,
where it enables to systematically
assess agent quality
through success criteria
that you can actually
configure through evaluations.
Now, how the system works is
through a centralized
observability architecture
that collects the telemetry
from all the AgentCore components,
whether it's Runtime or
Gateway or Identity or Memory,
and your tools through the microservices.
As your agents execute,
AgentCore automatically sends traces
to the observability component,
capturing every decision, every tool call,
and every interaction that was made.
The logs are open telemetry compatible,
which means that the logs
can be directly pipped
into your choice of
observability platform,
whether it's Dynatrace or
Datadog or Langsmith or Langfuse.
You can easily add random
and custom attributes
and business metadata
functions to your agent traces,
making observability directly relevant
to your business outcomes
and decision-making.
Now, that covers our AgentCore modules,
and remember that these are
all modular Lego blocks,
so you can pick and choose
whatever fits your production environment.
And with that, I'll hand it over to Roland
to do some closing comments.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I'm really excited
with observability, OTEL support,
is lets you kind of integrate
with your existing observability tools,
'cause we love our observability tools,
but our partners also
have some great tools.
So really excited about that as well.
Still a lot of challenges
in this space, right?
Cardinality and token costs.
You have lots and
thousands of microservices,
and you have to interrogate
all of those things, right?
And you're sending those over to LLMs
to make choices on your applications
that can bring up the cost.
That's why things like semantic search
and using that are so important, right?
Auditability requirements.
The more regulated your industry,
the more you have to think about things.
When policies are changing fast,
how do you deal with that?
Lots of issues there as well, right?
A lot of regulated industries,
require precise deterministic logic,
that's where your code is super important.
You're still gonna write
your microservices,
still gonna write your
container-based applications,
EKS, ECS, and a lot of cool
announcements there this week
as well, and your Lambda functions,
and you're still gotta deal
with things like data trust,
permissions, and all of these things.
And I'm really excited
with the frontier agents
that Matt announced
earlier yesterday, right?
These agents really implementing,
Swami talked about it,
kind of some of these DevOps
challenges that we have,
MLOps evaluations, and
really streamlining that.
But there's still a lot
of things to kind of worry
about with your existing DevOps,
your existing applications.
You might be using GitHubs,
DevOps, different things,
and now you have brand new patterns.
So these are still lots of challenges.
Hopefully, we work together,
discover them together,
out there in the ethos
as we work together and
build our systems, right?
In summary, our use cases must
be business-driven, right?
At the end of the day,
you must have valid business
reasons to build applications,
build systems, whether it's to save costs,
whether it's to provide new opportunities,
certainly not lots of new
patterns, generation of tools,
making it easier for your applications
to kind of create content,
lots of different use cases,
use accelerator, lots of best practices
in places like our solution
library and marketplace.
And all different places
have different accelerators
and best practices.
Integration continues to be important.
Things like gateways,
will really accelerate
your existing applications.
Define your development
methodology early, your MLOps,
your evaluations, your DevOps,
harden those practices when
you build your first agents.
And then over time, harden those practices
as you learn more and more.
It might be building up
a library of prompts,
introducing new practices
like LLM as a judge
to kind of evaluate as
new models come out.
So with that, I want to thank
you for spending your evening.
I hope you all have
great plans this evening
as you go out, and think about
these things agentically,
think about making
decisions over your dinners,
where you're going to eat agentically.
Thank you.
We'll share the QR code,
start building with AWS,
and use our Bedrock
AgentCore capabilities.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)